En este video quiero hablarles acerca de una
tercera forma de ver a las líneas rectas,
pero antes de visualizar esta tercera forma
de ver a las líneas rectas,
me gustaría repasar lo que ya hemos visto acerca de cuales son las formas,
en las cuales podemos escribir a una línea recta.
Habíamos visto por ejemplo la forma pendiente
ordenada al origen, que era "y" es igual a
"mx" más "b", que era algo parecido a esto.
Justo en el video pasado hablamos de una nueva
forma de ver a la línea recta,
que era la forma punto pendiente, que decía,
"y" menos "y1" es igual a "m" por "x" menos "x1"...
"y" menos "y1" es igual a "m" por
"x" menos "x1"...
Y por ejemplo, tenemos esta ecuación aquí
abajo que dice,
"y" menos 7, "y" menos "y1", es igual a -5,
-5 sería la pendiente, que multiplica a "x" menos 12,
"x" menos "x1".
Pues en este video quiero ver una tercera
forma de ver a las líneas rectas.
Y esta vez voy a hablar de la forma estándar
de ver a una línea recta.
Y cuando hablo de la forma estándar de ver q una línea recta, estoy pensando en la siguiente forma,
"ax" más "by" es igual a "c".
Y al final, lo primero que si quiero decirte
que es muy importante es que estamos hablando
de la misma línea recta, es decir,
podemos pasar de una forma a otra,
podemos pasar, por ejemplo,
de esta forma a esta forma o de esta forma a esta forma o regresarnos o como tú quieras.
Al final, son tres formas distintas de ver
a la misma línea recta.
Así que en este caso tengo tres ejercicios,
tres rectas que me gustaría pasar en la forma estándar.
Y la primera dice, "y" es igual a "3x" menos 8,
vamos a estrenar nuestra forma estándar
de ver a la línea recta,  que es "ax" más "by" igual a "c".
Así que déjame escribir esta ecuación otra vez aquí abajo, "y" es igual a "3x" menos 8.
Y aquí tengo mi función a mi línea recta
y bueno, lo más fácil y lo que se me ocurre
es restar "3x" de ambos lados de la ecuación.
Y me queda menos "3x" y del otro lado me queda
menos "3x" y ahora sí, voy a restar y hacer
las respectivas operaciones.
Menos "3x" aquí no se opera con nada, entonces
me queda "-3x" más "y"...
más "y" de color verde, esto es igual
y "-3x" y "3x" se cancelan,
"3x" menos "3x" se va y solamente me queda -8.
Y ¿qué crees? ya está en su forma estándar,
ya lo tenemos de la forma "ax" más "by" es
igual a "c", donde "a" vale -3,  "b" vale 1 y "c" vale -8.
Y date cuenta que empezamos con una recta que estaba en su forma pendiente ordenada al origen,
que por cierto para mi esta es mi forma
favorita de ver a una línea recta,
porque en esta forma, yo puedo ver claramente cual es la intersección con el eje de las "y"
y además puedo ver la pendiente, mientras en la forma estándar no es tan fácil ver la pendiente.
Pero bueno, aquí tenemos un segundo ejercicio
donde la pendiente vale -5,
y ¿cómo pasamos a la forma estándar?
Lo que hay que hacer y lo que se me ocurre
primero, es distribuir este -5 y multiplicarlo
tanto por "x" como por -12.
¿Y qué me va a quedar?
Pues me quedaría "y" menos 7, es igual a
-5 por "x" es "-5x" y después -5 por -12,
menos por menos me da más, y 5 por 12 es 60.
Y bueno, después voy a sumar 7 de
ambos lados de la ecuación,
lo que estoy haciendo es pasar este -7 del otro lado de la ecuación, para que se pueda simplificar con este 60.
y ¿Qué me quedaría?
más 7, más 7, de este lado izquierdo me
va a quedar solamente "y" -7 más 7 se va.
Y entonces me queda,
"y" es igual ¿a quién?
déjame cambiar de color...
"y" es igual a -5 por "x" menos "5x" y 60
más 7 es lo mismo que 67... más 67...
Y bueno, si yo lo que busco es la forma estándar
de mi recta, aquí lo tengo que hacer es sumar
"5x" de los dos lados de la ecuación,
para que yo pueda pasar este "-5x" del
lado izquierdo de mi ecuación.
Y así me va a quedar en la forma "ax" más
"by" igual a "c".
Y ¿qué me queda?
"y"más "5x" es igual... estos dos se cancelan
y solamente me quedan 67.
¡Y ya está! Aquí ya lo tengo de la forma estándar,
tal vez tengo a los términos un
poco desordenados, pero esto es exactamente
lo mismo que ver "5x" más "y" igual a 67,
Donde "a" valdría 5, donde "b" valdría 1
y en este caso "c" va a valer 67.
Y bueno, aquí tengo algo así como mixto,
no lo tengo ni de la forma punto pendiente,
ni de la forma pendiente ordenada al origen,
tengo algo raro y lo quiero pasar a la forma estándar.
Así que lo primero que voy a hacer, va a ser exactamente lo mismo que hice en el ejercicio pasado,
voy a distribuir este 4.
Y me queda, "3y" más 5 es igual a 4 por "x",
que es "4x" y después 4 por -9, que es -36.
Paso seguido, voy a sumar... bueno, de hecho
voy a restar 5 de ambos lados de la ecuación
con la idea de que este 5 se paso del otro
lado de la ecuación y se pueda simplificar
con este -36, así que menos 5, menos 5,
este -5 más 5 se van y solamente me que "3y" del
lado izquierdo y del lado derecho me queda
"4x" y después -36 menos 5,
lo cual me da -41... -41...
y después voy a pasar este "4x" del otro lado de la ecuación con signo contrario
y para esto lo que voy a hacer es restar "4x" de ambos lados de la ecuación.
Y me queda, "-4x"... de este lado le voy a poner "-4x"
y entonces me queda, "-4x" más "3y"...
"-4x" más "3y" del lado izquierdo de mi ecuación...
déjame cambiar de color...
"-4x" más "3y" y del lado derecho
me va a quedar...
éste y éste se van y me queda solamente -41.
¡Y ya lo tenemos aquí otra vez!
Ya lo tenemos en su forma estándar, de nuevo
lo tenemos de la forma "ax" más "by" es igual a "c".
Y ahora vamos al revés.
Qué pasa si nos dan la forma estándar y
yo lo quiero pasar, por ejemplo, a la forma...
a mi forma favorita, a la forma pendiente
ordenada al origen.
Es decir, vamos a escribirla aquí, la famosa
pendiente ordenada al origen,
la forma pendiente ordenada al origen
es "y" es igual a "mx" más "b".
Que pues esencialmente es despejar a "y" así
que vamos a agarrar la primera ecuación
y vamos a despejar a "y".
Tengo "5x" menos "2y" es igual a 15...  a 15 positivo.
Y después lo primero que voy a hacer es restar "-5x" de ambos lados de la ecuación,
menos "5x" de este lado, aquí más "5x" y aquí menos "5x" y estos dos se van.
Entonces solamente me queda que "2y", "-2y"
es igual a 15 menos "5x".
Y ahora lo que voy a hacer es dividir todo entre -2, lo que quiero es despejar a "y",
para estar en la forma pendiente ordenada al origen, así que, todo esto entre -2... -2 y -2 se va,
solamente me queda "y" del lado izquierdo de la ecuación, mientras que del lado derecho me queda,
15 entre -2, pues esto es -7.5 y
después menos entre menos me da más,
5 entre 2 es 2.5, así que a este
lo voy a sumar más "2.5x".
¿Si estamos bien? Sí.
Más "2.5x" y bueno, si lo quiero acomodar
esto para que se vea mucho más clara la forma
pendiente ordenada al origen,
me queda que "y" es igual a "2.5x" menos 7.5.
Y aquí, claramente ya se ve quien es la pendiente
y quien la ordenada al origen.
Ésta de aquí, ésta es la pendiente...
la pendiente... mientras que menos... no, no,
no, espérame... -7.5, todo esto de aquí
es la ordenada al origen o la intersección
con el eje de las "y"...
la intersección con el eje de las "y" y ya tengo el primero
ejercicio de la forma estándar a la forma
pendiente ordenada al origen.
Así que vamos a hacer el siguiente, el siguiente
dice "3x" más "6y" es igual a 25.
Y lo primero que voy a hacer es pasar este
"3x" del otro lado de la ecuación y me queda
que "6y" es igual a 25 menos "3x".
Y ahora voy a dividir todo entre 6 y me queda
que "y" es igual a 25/ 6 menos 3/6,
pero menos 3/6 es lo mismo que 1/2, -1/2 de "x"
y entonces esto es lo mismo que "y" es igual
a -1/2 de "x" más 25/6.
Y otra vez, ya sabemos que la pendiente es el coeficiente que está al lado de la "x",
esta es mi pendiente, mientras que ésta es la intersección con el eje de las "y". 25/6 es "b".
Y pues vamos a finalizar con este último ejercicio.
"9x" menos "9y" igual a 4.
Y en este ejercicio quiero proceder
de una manera distinta,
que te parece si lo primero que hago es dividir entre -9, entre -9 porque voy a despejar a "y".
Es exactamente lo mismo que hacerlo de la manera cotidiana solamente que quiero hacerlo un poco más
divertido y que te des cuenta que podemos llegar de dos maneras distintas al mismo resultado.
Así que voy a dividir todo entre 9... todo
entre 9... todo entre 9...
de hecho todo entre -9, me va a servir más
que tenga -9, porque lo que voy a hacer es
a la "y" positiva y entonces si de una vez
volvemos a la "y" positiva,
va a ser muy fácil despejar a "y".
9 entre -9 me da -1, -1 por "x" = "-x", -9
menos 9 se van, me queda más "y", del otro
lado me queda -4/9, es más,
déjame ponerlo aquí -4/9.
Porque ahora lo que voy a hacer es sumar "x"
de ambos lados de la ecuación y entonces
esta "x" va a pasar del otro lado y me va a quedar...
con color amarillo voy a poner a la "x" positiva,
para que se cancelen... más "x", más "x"
y entonces, "x" menos "x" se van
y solamente me queda que "y" es igual a "x" menos 4/9.
Y otra vez, ya aquí estamos en la
forma pendiente ordenada al origen,
porque la pendiente es
el coeficiente que está al lado de la "x",
que en este caso es 1, mientras que mi
ordenada al origen o "b"
o la intersección con el eje de las "y" es igual a -4/9.
Y ya está.